[Música]
[Aplausos]
como vamos a hablar de desobediencia y
desde que nacemos se nos educa se nos
cría a obedecer
en casa en familia cuando eres niño
obedeces obedeces recoge la cama no
pérez a tu hermano no insultes hace esto
haz lo otro comete la coliflor
por cierto lo de la comida la obsesión
por la comida como pediatra es algo
curioso esa obsesión de los padres por
comer
curiosamente luego como padres repetimos
lo mismo con nuestros hijos
pero dejamos la familia nos vamos al
colegio y que vuelva a pasar
a veces
y guarda silencio en clase no pegas a tu
compañero no corras por el pasillo
al fin y al cabo obedecemos
pero es que la sociedad nos obliga a
ello el ser humano es sociable por lo
tanto necesitamos reglas
qué pasaría en el tráfico que ya de por
sí es complicado si no hiciéramos caso
de las señales de tráfico
el caos el caos absoluto por lo tanto
hace falta obedecer
la clave es siempre
tenemos que obedecer siempre
os voy a poner un ejemplo
imaginaros que tiene el hospital es un
caso real
estoy en la unidad de neonatos
voy a poner un tratamiento a un recién
nacido que está enfermo y pautó
prescribe un tratamiento doy una orden
que la enfermera que me conoce lleva
conmigo muchos años y en experiencia
tiene conocimiento piensa dice no
no voy a cumplir la orden del pediatra
fijaros que a lo mejor esa forma de
actuar ha podido evitar una complicación
muy seria en un recién nacido
que ha habido ahí de diferente que le
hace que sea algo que tengamos que
hablar
la inteligencia
la enfermera ha utilizado sus
conocimientos su experiencia y ha
decidido que no siempre se debe obedecer
para ayudar a esto os plantea un giro en
vez de hablar de desobediencia
inteligente hablar de inteligencia
desobediente a mí personalmente me ayudó
mucho porque entonces en este caso
estéis viendo
que no es que desobedecer sea malo no no
es que es bueno es más es positivo y
hasta veces obligados
fijaros que la vida en sí es
desobediencia inteligente porque la vida
pasa
del agua a la tierra porque porque
tenemos ahora necesidad de ese cambio y
tenemos que cambiar para que no salgan
los miembros las manos
la ley natural de cómo ha evolucionado
en los animales es un proceso continuo
de desobediencia porque el hombre ha
dejado de andar a cuatro patas y estar a
dos
con lo que eso nos tiene ahora de las
lecciones fiscales si os dais cuenta
siempre hay un motivo por el que haya
que hacer un cambio es más vosotros
todos todos y cada uno de vosotros sois
el resultado final de una desobediencia
inteligente
por qué
el sistema inmune es muy complejo esta
interacción hay muchas moléculas células
y tienen un orden establecido que no se
debe de romper hay órdenes que se deben
cumplir
y que eso nos permite pues protegernos
de agentes externos infecciones también
de agentes internos de células malignas
que podemos tener nuestro cuerpo
bueno pues en esa obediencia obligada
del sistema inmunitario
en el embarazo vuestras madres rompieron
todo eso y hace que vuestro vosotros
mismos cómo embriones siise admitidos y
no seáis rechazados y al final aquí
estáis ahora entenderéis porque hay
muchas embarazadas tienen problemas
autoinmunes problemas del tiroides les
afecta mucho la gripe esa desobediencia
a veces también tiene sus efectos
secundarios pero aquí estáis todos y
cada uno sois lo que sois desobediencia
inteligente ahora la lleváis desde que
naces y como todo en la vida crece
madura se desarrolla y la desobediencia
también es así
la desobediencia aparte de ser la
desobediencia inocente de los niños
y debe evolucionar a la desobediencia
inteligente del adulto mientras tanto
hay que pasar por una fase crítica la
adolescencia
eso sí que es un máster en desobediencia
viajamos
venimos conmigo
nos vamos a ir de guadalajara viajamos
en el tiempo viajamos en el espacio
vámonos al siglo 15 y 16
que es el final de una época oscura
rígida donde la evidencia era sí o sí la
edad media y surge el renacimiento nos
vamos a ir a la cuna del renacimiento a
italia
y en concreto a la toscana en esa zona
tan pequeña italiana vamos a tener ese
frasco de la esencia de la desobediencia
inteligente
galileo galilei
nació en pisa estudió medicina estuvo
cuatro años su padre casi le obligó pero
desobedeció a su padre y no hizo
medicina él quiso hacer lo que le
apasionaba que eran las matemáticas las
matemáticas y la astronomía
en aquella época estaba establecido que
la tierra era el centro de todo en la
teoría geocéntrica de ptolomeo clásica
incuestionable
galileo retoma la historia y la teoría
heliocéntrica de copérnico de nicolás
copérnico es decir la tierra se mueve
lo que se queda quieto es el sol bueno
en esa época os imagináis cómo era la
autoridad pues por lo tanto juicio se le
juzgó como hereje se le obligó a
renunciar a sus creencias
pero volvió tuvo que ser otra vez
juzgado y nuevamente el juzgado y al
final en el exilio se tuvo que condenar
para que no hablara de este tema y es
clásica ya su final en que ante ese
tribunal que tantos años le había dicho
que eso no era posible ese abuelito que
ya no tenía energía sacó esa casta de
científico y directamente cuando ya lo
tenía energías su golpeó fuertemente
se mueve
pero se mueve fantástico
rebeldía absoluta desobediencia
inteligente
bueno galileo galilei es según albert
eisntein el padre de la ciencia gracias
a él se crea el método científico basado
en la observación
seguimos
qué decir del gran leonardo da vinci
talento puro el genio
pintor escultor arquitecto inventor
pero sobre todo artista
y un artista que muy poca gente ha
podido hacer algo de la historia es
hacer la simbiosis entre ciencia y arte
su arte necesita paciencia y para
dibujar el cuerpo humano esos dibujos
tan precisos que hoy en día han pasado
500 años el próximo año no lo vamos a
hacer el quinto centenario ni la
resonancia ni el tag permite hacer
dibujos tan precisos de lo que hizo
leonardo por eso tuvo que disecar el
cuerpo humano
qué significó eso enfrentarse otra vez
con la autoridad estaba prohibido a
hacer nada con el cuerpo humano se le
juzgó y se le grupo como para profanar
el cuerpo humano
y ha significado esa rebeldía de
leonardo pues ha cambiado la forma de
entender la medicina hasta entonces la
medicina se consideraba el cuerpo humano
como una observación externa hasta el
método clásico de galeno
con leonardo empezamos a dar importancia
al hombre desde dentro y esto va a
significar un cambio radical en la
medicina y en muchas especialidades que
vendrán después como por ejemplo la
cirugía gracias al gran leonardo
cambiamos dejamos italia
nos vamos a inglaterra
y cambiamos en el tiempo nos vamos a
mayo de 1796
qué ocurre en mayo de 1796 y en
inglaterra pues en concreto nos vamos a
ir a un pequeño pueblo
un pueblo que se llama berkeley
qué ocurre ahí lo que viene ahora es
magia
edward jenner edward jenner es un médico
un médico rural que vivía en su berkeley
y en observación
crea el método empírico que luego se
está usando en los ensayos clínicos se
fijo
que las mujeres que ordeñaban vacas que
esas vacas tenían viruela bovina
esas señoras no enfermaban de la viruela
y solamente tenían lesiones en las manos
jenner dijo
algo puede ser que esté pasando porque
estas señoras no enferman cuando la
viruela o recuerdo era una enfermedad
muy contagiosa y altamente mortal sin
tratamiento
decidió bueno pues lo que voy a hacer es
que voy a un trozo de esa
sustancia que tienen las vaqueras y se
lo voy a poner a un cuerpo que todavía
no ha desarrollado la enfermedad
y ahí tenemos
esa imagen
que es inoculando a un niño de 8 años
james y ese niño
jane feaps es el hijo de su jardinero
edward jenner para hacer esto pide
permiso a su padre consentimiento
informado
con esto empezó a hacer los estudios y
sacaron más de 23
edward jenner postuló que esto era una
forma de poder prevenir esta enfermedad
altamente mortal y se fue a la royal
society de londres y allí ante toda la
sociedad científica contó su experimento
fatal
desacreditado esto que es está rompiendo
la orden y las órdenes en medicina
imposible que esto pueda salir por lo
tanto desacreditado pero eso no se quedó
solamente en el mundo médico salto a la
sociedad
de campo
qué es esto
mira la viruela humana se llama small ox
la viruela bovina vacuna se llama code
box sabéis cómo es el humor británico no
en ese puntito ellos crean de kout poch
que es la marca de la vaca y esto es a
nivel social se quiero un momento social
para derrumbar a edward jenner de hecho
ya no se le consideraba un médico se le
consideraba un brujo que lo que estaba
haciendo era atentar contra la salud de
la gente de su propio pueblo de berkeley
y esta ilustración que veis aquí veis
como el pobre jenner inoculando a las
personas queman sedes preparaba con un
brebaje se les ponía la inoculación y a
partir de ahí que pasaba se
transformaban eran monstruos eran medio
hombres medio vacas toros esto que veis
aquí fue muy popular en inglaterra
pues hoy en día esta ilustración que
veis aquí de campo que sabéis dónde está
en el british museum de londres es el
orgullo de la medicina inglesa
y por qué
300 millones no es un número son vidas
son las vidas que en esa época a nivel
mundial se estipula que la viruela
mortal mataba
ese brujo que puso esa zona del niño de
una vaquera vaquera que por cierto era
también conocida a sara names de una
vaca que también conocida que era la
vaca blossom
ha conseguido evitar 300 millones de
vidas
esto ha cambiado el rumbo de la medicina
recordar ahora porque sabéis el concepto
de vacuna
la vacuna viene gracias a las vacas de
género
hoy en día es la única enfermedad
contagiosa que la oms ha declarado
erradicada desde 1980 y se ha abierto
una fuente de investigación y
tratamiento que son las vacunas la
actividad sanitaria más eficiente que
podáis
contar
vidas y vidas no solamente aquí sobre
todo el tercer mundo eso es clave
esto fue el inicio y se considera el
padre de la inmunología y un siglo más
tarde
louis pasteur desarrolla gracias a ellos
tenemos a las vacunas una gran gran acto
de desobediencia inteligente para
terminar os voy a contar mi opinión de
lo que es
la desobediencia cinco consejos que
quiero dar utilizar los cinco consejos
que es una crónico la cee de
conocimiento sin conocimiento es
imposible ser suficiente la ignorancia
es incompatible la ere riesgo tenéis que
ser valientes tenés que asumir riesgos
la de estima en concreto autoestima
confiar más en vosotros tenéis que
valorar mucho más lo que sois siempre
actitud positiva ha sido positiva os va
ayudar mucho a ir hacia adelante la cee
curiosidad no os quedéis nunca parados
intentar aprender siempre no vale el
dinamismo de mental existe no para
intentar aprender siempre y la última la
e para mí la más importante ética todo
lo que hagáis hacerlo siempre bajo el
prisma de la ética no mal eficiencia en
un timón no no cede y en la
beneficiencia intentar siempre hacer el
bien
porque recordar que todos tenemos el
deber de obedecer y el derecho de no
hacerlo pero de forma inteligente os
saludé como obedientes me despido de
vosotros como desobedientes
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]